hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought this big piece of land and
are prototyping a more sustainable way
of living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous video you could
see us cleaning up our future kitchen
which is going to be an important
element of eating more sustainable
but besides the building it's also
important where you actually get your
food from
so in today's video we're going to talk
more about that
veggies yes where do we get our food and
how can we eat more sustainably
luckily we have a couple of friends that
live close by and they grow their own
food they make these great baskets
and we are one of the lucky people to
buy these baskets
and to get our food in a more
sustainable way
and funny fact is that this couple that
grows these veggies
are also the reason why we bought this
piece of land
yeah so we're gonna meet them first
we're gonna visit their house
and then we're going to see their farm
where these young farmers grow all these
[Music]
vegetables
[Music]
hi i'm sarah hi i'm luna we've been
living here now for about two and a half
years
and we'll take you around the farm but
we thought we'd start here
with the house because this is where we
started so
yeah we started renovating this side of
the house two and a half years ago
and later like uh three or four months
ago
we did the other side of the house
really
all the parts could you show me the yeah
sure
so this is our house we got it it was
from
an old guy a shepherd he was used to
grow ships and here and he was taking
everyone
ships to the mountains in the summer to
have the grass on the top of the
mountains and so as my parents lived
really nearby when i was a child i was
spending a lot of time in this house
with the shepherd and when he died he
we irritated it and then we renovated it
it's nice and cool
in here yeah it's hot outside here we
it's like like with a double glass
and we put before the plaster also that
the mesolation because the sun
really needs up in here so this is our
guest
little guest house in this side of the
house we opened that
door we painted and restored the
the roof we clean
the walls they are really really old and
it's for the volunteers you mentioned
yeah yeah
it's for the volunteers because we have
a lot of demand for like of all
people who wants to learn and work with
us but we had no space for us
we almost did not now we are starting to
have some space for resin for who wants
to join us so let's go outside and then
i can show you our animals
we have some that we mainly keep for
the menu they give we give
also horses one of them is a draft horse
is huge and
we are willing to start to use it to
work the fields as well with us
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a puppy
[Music]
and now we have to go look for the
horses because they have
all of this space to walk around
sometimes they are down there sometimes
they are up there but
usually in the summer and the odd hours
of the day
they prefer to be down there because
it's cooler with all the trees and the
water
[Music]
he is ringo and he is ventura ringo is
with us for
two years already and ventura ag does
this for us for
six months so far and they are amazing
they poo a lot and so we use their
manure for fertilizer our garden
and the ringo as you can see is huge
bigger than ventura much bigger he's a
draft horse and we are willing to
use him as our helper in the garden
he can pull some trailers and even dig a
bit the soil if we need
and we can also when we have some free
time
not so far can dry them
we did this barn we did last um in the
end of the last winter
because we were saving the hay in the
barn
right next to the house and it's very
dangerous in the summer with the fires
if we keep
the amount of hay together with the
house it's really dangerous
so we built this barn and that one
as well this one will be the new
house for the horses and now they are
living in that blue one
we did by ourselves me and sarah two
years ago
but that will say they will stay the
compost house
let's see the chickens here they are one
two three four five
six fresh eggs yesterday i got more six
as we keep the chickens
free sometimes they have to go looking
for the eggs oh you find the eggs there
yeah i found they are putting there
and do you know where the chickens are
now they could be anywhere they can be
anywhere
so now we have 17 chickens
three of them are in this first
part with the chicks we got
them from the chickens in the coop
they reproduce by themselves they find
even places in the shrubs to keep like
eating the eggs for three weeks and then
they come back home
with a lot of them and now
these ones little ones will be in
five months the chickens will be giving
out these delicious eggs
how many eggs do you have like a week or
a day or you know
usually we can have like 16 18 eggs
they they put almost one egg a day each
chicken
if we find them you eat a lot of eggs
uh yeah we eat a lot of eggs and you
also eat the chicken
well we the males we let them grow a bit
and then we are not able to do that
so we give them to my mom she kills them
and then
she gives the she gives it to us already
cooked
and then it's good she just do not tell
to sarah doesn't talk to sarah because
she prefers to not know there that she
can say
so in this little greenhouse is where we
grow
our seedlings to later transplant for
the fields
it's looking a bit empty now
because we are in the end of the season
we have
almost everything planned we have some
tomatoes still remaining in here some
onions
some broccoli and some artichoke
and parsley and
basilico so this is the place where we
live and
it's awesome to have all the seedlings
and the little plants
right next to our bed but now we'll show
you the place where everything goes
and everything grows where you make the
money we're going to make the money yeah
i will try
but before we go to their farm i had two
more questions for nunu
questions i think we could learn from
first up highway
so they live around here and the whole
land is this area
and the highway is right here so you
live there
yeah and there is the highway right yeah
there is the highway how does it make
you feel
is it well i don't like it that much
i remember while they were constructing
it
we were already starting to do the big
house my parents
house and so we stayed and we get
used to it uh it makes a little bit of
noise
but we want to grow bigger trees for
protectors a bit more also nice
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i hear it but in the night there
are some busy times
but usually in the night it calms down a
lot and down there we don't feel that
much and we
hear much more the birds so what is your
best
solution against the highway sounds like
more bird sounds more trees
ignore it yeah you should try to ignore
it
because we all use them in the end and
then one last question about getting
water
since we're currently also looking into
this topic and he mentioned they also
use a well
just like we plan to do
this water is still running from the
well
the remaining water gets stuck there but
my dad would
put the pipe inside the well so five
meters away from the sprout
they build before we start to live in
here
they built this well is only two meters
deep because they start to dig and then
they found a really hard
rock really hard granite so they start
exploding a bit but they could only go
two meters
deep and so it's the water we have
sometimes we spend it really quick
in the summer when we forget the top
open it's just gone and then we don't
have water
and we have to wait for a little bit not
that longer because then
the water starts to accumulate again in
the well
and then the water is
pulled by an electric water pump
and then we have a little little
pressure
tank to keep the water under under
pressure
so pump and pressure yeah pump blue and
the pressure tank is the gray
so you've seen the house so now let's go
and see
the farm so our market going when we
grow our vegetables it's about a five
minute drive
well welcome to the quinto de fotono
market garden i guess you could call it
where we grow the veg
that we sell um i'm just gonna show you
three of our main fields i mean it's all
terraced here so we have a lot of
different ones
even i can't remember all of the
different names that we give them
and then later on we'll go down and have
a look at the
barn where we do our
packaging and the cleaning station and
all of that
and so this is capitol tank because
there's a big
water reservoir there that we'll see
afterwards um this is my
personal favorite um field um
so we did the first thing we did here
was we got a digger
and we made some sort of two meter deep
trenches lines and we filled that with
organic matter
and like wood and then we planted our
fruit trees
um along with their support trees
so here we have
an apple tree and then it's got
fast-growing support
supporting trees around it and then
between these tree
trenches i guess you could call them
then we have four four veg beds
courgettes old peas that need to come
out
um this is we're trialling this kind of
trellis thing this year for our tomato
plants and it seems to be going
relatively well
i just need to keep them going we've got
some lettuce here going to seed
i want this variety i like this variety
so i'm going to let it
um here we have a row of
raspberries with
plum trees actually there are some plums
already growing we can go check it out
maybe
and then i have some coriander going to
see some kale
oh blue tomatoes
that's super pretty they're my favorite
and they taste good as well
and we've tried to pick one variety of
fruit tree per
kind of row but in that row we'll have
um different types of plums trees so
that they
give at different times during the year
and don't
come like they're not ready all at once
basically
and it's cool because this one is almost
ready but the next one along
is gonna be ready maybe next week or in
two weeks
you see they're really green still so
all peaches
all different varieties that will help
give it different times which is really
good for csa and veg box
to not have it all at once and then we
have our first pairs they're really
pretty i've never seen purple pears
they're really purple um
and then this next row we have asparagus
you can't see it because it's going to
seed but this is the asparagus
so this is called this will last you
know about as long as a tree basically
20 years it will be in the ground but
you have to wait three years for it to
give
and here we've got pear trees yeah are
you taking them out
what do you mean it's in the root or
where does it grow
yeah so this is an asparagus
that has gone to seed so this will have
looked like the asparagus you have on
your plate
and it's become this but it because
the asparagus plant most of it's under
the earth so you have to wait
three years for it to get fully
established before you start cutting
basically the sprouts that come out so
we'll cut this
soon um and just leave it
and then it will start giving again in
the spring
and that's when we'll harvest it um
you've seen the tree rose i guess
which are also mixed i have a lot of
perennial herbs in there
but we focus more on long-term stuff in
the
in the trenches in the roast and then
between these
uh fruit tree rose we have four
veg beds um currently i've got
on this side cucumbers growing with
onions
i'm not sure if i'm gonna sell them
fresh or cured yet it depends on how
they grow
and then here i've got kale which is
growing really nicely
as well and onions as well so we try to
put at least two varieties in each veg
bed if we can that's in order to make
the best use of space so for example the
cucumber plant will go up
but then this leaves a nice bit of bed
free for other stuff like for example
onions and then the same thing here so
the kale
will as we harvest the leaves
we'll just keep growing up above the
onions
and then when we take the onions out i
actually probably plant something else
lower down beetroot or spinach oh look
here there's three cucumbers
crazy
so this is a highly productive plant at
the moment he's decided to
produce three cucumbers at the same time
we might have to harvest one of those
so it doesn't go bad we have some
cinnamon basil
so these kind of things like we like to
have but they're not best sellers
because you know people don't really
know what to do with them
apart from smell them they smell really
nice here cinema
cinnamon basil yeah so it's a little bit
purple
um so this is going to be our last
rather late um
seeding or planting luna
okay planting of potatoes
um so the potatoes are already in the
ground
and nuno is now um covering it
with some sawdust there's actually a
waste product from
factory down the road and they used to
make pallets
so he came and delivered all of this
this morning so now
luna's going to lay it on the ground and
that's going to
protect the soil it's going to retain
moisture
and it's going to keep the temperature
down as well so this
is our main
and only barn actually so we use
it to store our tools we use it to prep
the boxes and here we have our new
addition this year
which is the washing station um which is
like been life-changing it's really
helped us so this
table table with holes in it is really
useful you just
so for stuff like carrots and beetroots
and stuff like that you just lay them
here and then i take my pressure
hose and just wash them here and then we
have this
window which i forgot i have to open
from the inside
and this is then when i where i'll be
receiving all of the
freshly prepared and washed veg and then
the boxes i'll set them up here
with the name of the client and then
they just and this is where i do the
weighing and
kind of prep it and then they'll go
out to the van so once the vegetables
are ready they either go
into a crate like the one you saw before
or they go to the local market
so let me show you that
[Music]
hi so here we are at our local
market in power so during the week
we do the bench boxes and then we come
here on the weekend to sell our excess
produce so as you can see it's still
quite a lot of stuff
that we have to sell um
we really like coming to market it's
more we get to speak a lot more to our
clients
there's a lot of international people
living in the hills as well so it's nice
to get to know them
and we're here along with some other
local producers
so you know have a look it's a nice
market and
maybe see you soon
and finally we sat down with sara nunu
to ask some tough questions
like can you sustain yourselves do you
like the work what are the challenges
things we might all learn from
two and a half years ago yeah two and a
half years ago
huh
yeah actually my family always farmed
but just by
themselves but when i was choosing my
the green university a friend of mine
like
cent for the air like ah farming
engineering
and so i put that in the end of the list
like
never waiting to enter in and then i did
it
and so yeah am i because i were
while i was living in the city and i was
working in an office and
i just wanted to find a job that was
more active and more outdoors
um and i had a podcast about
permaculture um and decided that that
made a lot of sense
mainly the agroforestry system so
combining sort of veg
with trees fascinated me from the first
time i heard it and so that's what we're
doing happy
it's exhausting we have to like it and
we do like it
then you also enjoy the when you rest
yeah when's that
um i would grow
yeah like find the barrier between
work and life um sometimes the lack of
preparation
i guess
without having everything set up yeah
because when you
uh as you are working with the seasons
you have some jobs that have to
be done in that time and if you miss it
because you're not prepared or
first if you are not prepared it will
take much longer to do the job
and you will delay the job and then you
lose the time when you should be doing
the job and then that
gives you more extra job you wouldn't
need if you could be than
that job and that time yeah
yeah i received a message from one of
your
colleagues katarina she was um in the
area looking for land so katarina
came to visit with adrian
and we had seen land nearby
when we were looking for a place to
garden um
but it was far too big for what we
wanted to do so we took them around
and yeah we're happy that you guys are
our new
kind of neighbors okay the city would be
not neighbors at all but here it's
almost
what you call the grass patches i
thought they were really cool
yeah and the fact you have the full hill
like from the bottom from the stream
to the top of the hill the big rock like
for fires and everything
you can manage it much better than if
you have just part of a hill
and because it was burned and we were
looking for burnland in that time
well i was born a foreigner i was born
uh grew up in france so
i feel pretty at home surprisingly so
but i guess
i've moved around a lot so i'm
comfortable with my foreign status
oh it's great because the portuguese
people is going abroad
or to lisbon airport or coimbra so
naturally some people have to come
so even for the old people the the old
ones they they like it because they see
someone who likes
the places and who wants to stay while
they
send and they doubters and grandsons and
they don't want to stay so yeah the land
has to
be occupied and worked by someone and
it looks like now with more foreigners
who are
enjoying here
intense yeah
um but yeah i think so this year we're
gonna try and find
some more time for some
personal projects of ours yeah um
to also focus on to kind of make it a
little bit
more diverse in our day-to-day life
are you going boring no they i'm going
on a date
yeah it's diversified it is intense
but we
it hasn't been easy
so far um the nice thing is
that well mainly we're a bit behind on
our marketing
um but we're seeing that as we're
starting to get the fruit
from the fruit trees that's checked
everything's getting slightly easier
um we may have to start
selling slightly less locally
in order to make ends meet so to speak
so we're considering
selling in cuimbra which is our nearest
city
just because it's hard to get enough
clients to sustain a csa
if it's just in a rural setting everyone
a lot of people have fruit trees a lot
of people have summer
gardens um so we just need there's
we're still gonna make some changes and
adjustments in order to make that work
come and visit yeah um
not just working but also all the
projects going on here there's more
there's more more going on around here
than you'd expect
but i mean you could also mention if you
want like we need people to help out i
don't know if this is a good place for
you guys but uh yeah we definitely need
people to help out and we've recently um
finished
uh a room and with a private bathroom
for to receive long-term volunteers
uh in mainly spring and autumn i think
that's
those are the times that we need the
most help but also the nicest times to
come
and visit because it gets pretty cold in
the winter and pretty hot
in the summer so and keep wild
okay are we getting our souvenirs
this guy looks like he wants to go
thank you you can go see maybe he'll
migrate to yours
should we put him on another flower so
yeah that was sara nunu
it's been really nice actually to have
them around it's like having our
local friends that are still young and
we don't have many of those around
and hopefully soon we can use their
vegetables to cook them in this kitchen
probably still going to take a while
because this kitchen is still pretty
rough
and actually next week's update number
28 we're gonna do
uh we're gonna show our current
challenges where we do every eight video
so video eight eighteen and twenty eight
and we're also gonna do a q a so if you
have any questions you wanna get
answered
make sure to post them in the comments
below and
vote on questions you like so they rise
up so we can answer them
and you can really ask anything so go
wild and see you next week